pulling back the curtain
now from Biden's allies and the doj it
was collaborators in the Press we're
going to get to phase two of the
operation get Trump because it's already
underway so if the doj can't indict him
out of their race it's going to be up to
the regime media to step up and wound
him badly politically that means framing
his presidency as an existential threat
to democracy how many times you've heard
that imagine if that were a drinking
game now enter the New York Times with
its piece titled Trump and allies Forge
plans to increase Presidential Power in
2025 and limit the independence of
federal agencies now reporters Maggie
Haberman Charlie Savage and Jonathan
Swann essentially want readers to
believe that a huge swath of the federal
government should work not to carry out
the president's Mission but to act as a
check against the president's mission
now the times warns that Trump intends
to strip employment protections from
tens of thousands of career civil
servants making it easier to replace
them if they don't carry out his agenda
now of course I know what you're all
thinking out there you're thinking wait
a second wait a second do you mean that
the president of the United States can't
fire federal employees who aren't doing
their jobs
well of course like clockwork mess NBC
steps in for the assist
if this didn't send a chill down the
spine of those who care about democracy
I really don't know what what this is
textbook fascism if you love Mussolini
you will love what Donald Trump is
talking about for 2025. Donald Trump the
first major candidate in American
history to say outright I want a
presidential dictatorship
morning jokes
I guess Besh loss a historian does not
know the Constitution remember the
founders only set out three branches of
government the judicial the legislative
and the executive article two read it
fellas gives the president the authority
over the Executive Branch after all he's
the nation's chief executive still with
me but the left depends on a fourth
branch of government don't they the
administrative branch
they expect that Branch will stop
policies they don't like and they don't
want being implemented
and forever grumpy scribblers like Ann
Applebaum at the Atlantic are very
worried that taming the bureaucracy As
Trump and DeSantis said they both want
to do would mean losing the expert class
experts
Alexander vinman and Anthony fauci
this is a Playbook that's designed to
destroy whatever checks and balances
there are in the system to remove
potential critics
ombudsmen anybody who can check
Presidential Power it's also designed to
remove experts
and naturally the times is also
horrified that a Republican president
would work to end the weaponization of
our Intel agencies as well
he plans to scour the intelligence
agencies State and defense bureaucracies
for political bias
what a scandal
can't believe Donald Trump would
actually do that look the real question
here is this
who governs America
do the voters govern America through
their elected officials or does a
permanent bureaucracy that significantly
constrains the power of elected
officials run the government
now the times POV is if you elect
liberals great but if a conservative
wins the presidency then the bureaucracy
should be able to resist the president's
agenda with everything they've got
now the administrative State worked
against Trump 24 7. and not just at
Justice when he tried to push through
executive orders on immigration lawyers
and bureaucrats in the agencies tried to
step in and stop him at every turn
and when he told the Pentagon I remember
this that he wanted to end the war in
Afghanistan oh they all balked delayed
and stymied his decision-making was so
obvious now President Reagan ran into
the same trouble his State Department
worked against his agenda in many ways
and this has essentially been the case
in almost every Republican
Administration since
but when Biden issued a blatantly
unconstitutional executive order to
forgive student loans
there was not a peep from any of the
lawyers at any of his administrative
agencies at least nothing reported no
leaks none of that ditto with his stop
evictions move to try to help renters
and by the way this game I I want to
point this out tonight it's not just
rigged to hurt Trump or maybe DeSantis
because again both of them are serious
about civil service reform
it's about blocking you the American
people
let's be very clear about about all of
this
everyone now should understand that the
career civil service at State the dod
and doj support the Democrat Party
across the board and most of the
agencies as well
this is why Trump at the outset had so
much trouble getting the DHS to stop
illegals from crossing our border
now Obama moved to switch so many
political appointees to Career positions
before he left office you know why
because he's smart that's why he did it
but he didn't hear any objection we none
of us did from people like Maggie or
Jonathan or Charlie then at least I
don't remember correct me if I'm wrong
but I wonder why we didn't hear much of
a uproar about what Obama did I'll tell
you why because they prefer that the
permanent liberal bureaucracy has the
final say in everything
for us conservatives democracy is a
process you vote we hope your votes
counted
then elected officials are supposed to
do what the voters want what they
campaigned on
but for the last democracy is an outcome
if it's not dedicated to the goal of the
global Elites it's a dictatorship or
it's fascist it's also predictable